my theory is ridiculous kill us
yes yes
[Music]
[Applause]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that knee needs you to skippity
dum dum that subscribe button yes yes if
you haven't seen the astronomical rise
of the series skippity toilet over the
last few months get your head out of the
toilet and let me tell you that no one
and I mean no one has seen this much
success so quickly on YouTube before as
I write this episode The Channel's
Creator defa ha I can't say his name can
I fine how about I make it classier for
you the Fook Bo m is getting somewhere
between three and four billion views a
month with a B those are numbers that
are so big they'd make Mr Beast blush
it's not just a lot of random views
either people are sticking around for
this thing the channel had about one and
a quarter million subscribers when it
posted the first skibity toilet video
back in February now just five months
later it's already past 20 million so
yeah to say that this thing has taken
over YouTube it'd be a major
understatement in one of the episodes
one of the titular skimpity toilets
literally destroys YouTube HQ in a not
so subtle metaphor for how this show has
broken the website skippity toilet has
fully taken advantage of YouTube's push
for shorts content and it is rode that
wave to create a level of virality that
has never been seen before so those are
the numbers but what is it well it's a
head in the toilet
yep it's some Gmod animations singing a
song the internet is truly a weird and
wonderful place no if I'm being
completely serious that's just how the
whole thing starts as the series goes on
the whole thing evolves into a full-on
cinematic war between toilets with human
heads and people with camera heads
complete with massive Titans mind
control and wait for it Hidden Lore and
I gotta say after binging every episode
of the series multiple times getting
that darn song permanently etched into
my brain what became clear to me was
that this goofy meme show wasn't just
about being LOL so Random it's also not
content just remaining as an epic toilet
action anime yeah that doesn't sound
good probably should rephrase that one
instead there's an entire meta story
buried in this thing a story about the
changing world of entertainment and the
fight for survival of art yeah this
this man's face in the toilet he's
trying to teach us a profound lesson
about the meaning of Art and once you
see the story that's hiding right in
front of your eyes it becomes clear
where the story is ultimately gonna end
so grab grab your knob toilets plungers
and kprl speakers loyal theorists as we
flush ourselves deep into the fever
dream that is skippity toilet now the
details for the base story here are
pretty straightforward the whole thing
starts when a man's head appears out of
a toilet and starts singing a mashup of
the 2007 song Give It To Me by Timbaland
and the 2022 Turkish song called Damn
yes yes by bisserking but things quickly
escalate from there the toilet heads
start to spread pretty soon we see an
army of these toilets marching or rather
sliding their way down the street
military parade style they clearly pose
a threat considering they run over
people they shoot lasers they even
transform humans into more Skitty
toilets pretty soon they've established
their own cult like religion a police
presence they even have themselves a
leader of the Army in the form of the
G-Man from half-life for those who don't
know in the half-life games the G-Man is
described as this Sinister
interdimensional bureaucrat he has this
strange reality bending power so why not
just throw him into a show about evil
toilet men very quickly it becomes
apparent that the people of this
universe are no match for the toy toilet
Terrors at a Time episode 6 rolls around
we pretty much stop seeing humans all
together enter the cameraman people with
cameras for heads pretty
self-explanatory but it quickly becomes
clear that these characters serve both
literally and figuratively as our point
of view pretty much all episodes are
shown from the perspective of one of
these cameramen often ending with the
POV character either giving a thumbs up
to one of their comrades or being killed
at the hands of one of the skivity
toilets this ragtag group of cameramen
have made it their mission to eliminate
the skibity scourge they form an
organized militia they fortnite dance
away from the police and then they form
unlikely alliances with other species
that inhabit this world the speakerman
and the TV men to other groups of
creatures that are just here for some
reason probably better suited for a
Radio Shack than the front lines and
together they plan to protect the planet
from these porcelain Pirates and yeah
that's pretty much about it in terms of
broad Strokes the rest of the series
basically follows a fairly standard
formula well I mean as standard as a
show about sentient monsters from Bed
Bath and Beyond gets we constantly see
the cameraman inventing some new
technology such as their giant toilet
kicking boss robots in turn the toilets
repurpose the discarded remains of their
fallen foes to become more and more
powerful this cycle of escalation
repeats over and over again eventually
leading to where we currently are in the
story with giant Kaiju level battles
between the G-Man toilet and the various
Titan robots that are created or
partnered with the cameraman and that to
99.9999 of people is what the story of
the series is but I'm here to tell you
it is so much more than that the battle
between the toilet heads and the
cameraman is really symbolic of the
battle between YouTube content and
traditional Medias like the film
industry yes I'm feeling okay and no I
don't want your long-sleeved jacket even
though it looks very pleasant and warm
skippity toilet is at its core a story
about how entertainment is changing and
how the series Creator defic boem is
gonna be the one that merges those two
worlds together it sounds insane right I
know that's why I'm so excited about
this one let me explain it to you as you
might or might not know this series is
littered with models assets and
references to an age gone by on the
internet an age before YouTube
yeah for our gen Z and frankly most of
our Millennial audience there was a time
where internet videos didn't solely
exist under the careful watch at Google
and YouTube in the beginning the world
of internet video was splintered off
from each other sites like new grounds
albino black sheep and e-bombs world is
where you'd go to find the memes viral
videos and animations this is where
internet meme culture truly began yeah
Charlie we're going to Candy Mountain
let's be too internet Boomer about it
but there was a time that when you saw a
funny video you'd have to send it to
your friends via email yeah that
platform that your parents use for work
these days it used to be where you got
all your lulls from like the Numa Numa
guy and I'm a snake and one of the
biggest styles of video that arose from
this early internet age was the genre
that would eventually come to be known
as the YouTube poop ironically enough
the style of a YouTube poop just
predated the age of YouTube these videos
would involve taking Clips or assets
from TV film and music and just mashing
them all together into an Unholy stream
of Consciousness there's only one real
solution to this map
[Music]
um a straight Christmas Street a cup of
hail oh no Luigi we gotta get rid of
this trash before it turns me all the
way into a coupon
wow that says the internet back then
very different but still very much the
same by the way I didn't edit that clip
at all that is it unedited and it's 240p
goodness did these videos make sense no
was it insane absolutely did any of it
matter who cares anything goes it was
the earliest days of online video for
the first time in history you could
literally make anything you wanted and
upload to a website anything that came
out of your head in the 80s and 90s if
you wanted to make your own movie you
needed a video camera the ability to cut
edit film a platform to share your
Creations all of which were either
prohibitively expensive difficult to
achieve or quite frankly just didn't
exist in the early 2000s though free
software like Windows Movie Maker opened
up the world of filmmaking to a wider
audience than ever one company that
really embraced the wild west nature of
the internet was valve today they're
best known for creating steam but back
in the day believe it or not the huge to
make video games they were responsible
for tentpole series like Half-Life
Counter-Strike portal Team Fortress DOTA
valve dominated the gaming scene and the
one game that truly embodied both their
gaming ethos and their Embrace of the
online was Gary's Mod Gary's Mod was a
Sandbox game where players could mess
around with the physics objects and
assets found in valve's popular
franchises and then use those to create
their own little movies games and shorts
this eventually evolved into the
creation of Source Filmmaker in 2013 a
video editing tool that allowed creators
to more easily create funny videos just
like they had with Gary's mod and this
proved to be a godsend for YouTube poop
creators if you've ever seen a video
featuring characters from Team Fortress
2 doing insane things it's probably
created using sfm
[Music]
in fact de fuke boam creator of skippity
toilet as we all know originally made a
name for himself online by making these
sorts of videos sfm content exactly like
this I mean unless I'm wrong skippity
toilet seems like it still is being
created in sfm so why are the big trip
down memory lane well I believe that
those edgy videos those YouTube poops
that came and went with internet Trends
I believe that those are what the toilet
heads and skippity toilet represent look
at the evidence first there's the fact
that the characters are literally
toilets the place where you poop like a
YouTube poop pretty direct connection
there second there's the fact that the
heads of all the skippity toilets are
straight from Gary's Mod Half-Life sfm
drawn yet another direct connection
there's also some more subtle hints as
well if you look between the lines in
episode 4 there's a subtle background
detail that shows how humans become
toilet people as soon as they're exposed
to the influence of the toilets we pan
across a normal restaurant to toilets
March in and suddenly people are
transformed into more toilet heads some
of those toilet heads even rise through
the ranks appearing in later episodes as
leaders of the toilet Army it is the
definition of virality the toilet people
are a disease that's spreading just like
a video going viral in the early days we
also know that the events of the series
are happening sometime in the past in
episode 20 after going toe-to-toe
against the G-Man the camera Titan flies
away flying past two very important
buildings the Twin Towers notice here
how it's an exact replica straight down
to the Spire at the top of one of those
buildings this tells us that the events
of the series predate the events of
September 11 2001. now admittedly
YouTube poops didn't exist back then
they originated back in 2004 but
websites like Newgrounds did exist back
then and Gmod videos were also big in
the early internet days like around 2006
so while it's not an exact timeline
match this toilet world isn't meant to
be some dystopian future instead it's
much more of a dystopian past a
reference to an earlier time gone by
also just take a look at the way that
the skibety toilets get stronger
throughout the 50 episode series while
the cameramen develop new technology and
techniques to get the upper hand in the
battles the toilets instead repurpose a
remix they reuse the stuff that the
cameraman leave behind if that Spirit of
remixing isn't just the pure essence of
what is YouTube poop I don't know what
is and then look what you have on the
flip side you have the film music and
television industry literally
represented by audio visual equipment
cameras speakers TVs it does not get
more direct than that who else would
serve as the perfect antagonist for the
literal embodiment of YouTube poop than
Legacy Media digital content like
YouTube poops are made from reusing and
rehashing content from those three
Industries just like how the skippity
toilets get stronger by repurposing the
tech that they find on the camera
speaker and TV men need more proof the
camera speaker and TV men be in
metaphors for the big three media
Industries has actually been teased
throughout the entirety of the series
back in the beginning of skippity toilet
when we were just dealing with toilets
and cameras we could see a clear
hierarchy amongst the ranks of the
cameras though the grunts were all the
small closed circuit TV style cameras
the more advanced and the more movie
like the camera became the higher up it
was the big movie studios were literally
the most powerful entities also take a
look at how the TV Titan goes about
destroying the toilets it uses this
South
pull out like the old the old HX intro
sound
foreign
furthermore there's the main theme song
that's used by the speakermen whenever
they attack that sweet Bop is the 1985
song Everybody Wants to Rule the World
by Tears for Fears who apparently are
still touring good for them not only is
this song very on the nose in terms of
the theme for the series two factions at
War trying to rule the world but it's
also just an old song from the 80s it's
dated just like the media it's meant to
represent in the series media that in
the real world is actively fighting off
the digital video threat but there's
something off about that right it feels
like the series wants us to be rooting
for the cameraman in fact there's this
one scene in episode 49 that clearly
establishes the toilet heads as the bad
guys occasionally throughout the series
you'll have a character speak in some
distorted voice what's actually going on
there is that they're speaking in
reverse and in that particular episode
the TV says to the toilet what sounds
like you are so bad when the whole
thing's reversed and cleaned up
so big
but uh there is no world where we should
be rooting four traditional media rights
especially when you're talking about a
digital series I know the show's odd but
the idea that we're supposed to be
sympathizing with some of the least
sympathetic Industries on the planet
seems like a step too far Meanwhile
we're supposed to dislike the internet
video side I mean the series got popular
because of Internet videos spoiler alert
singing meme face in a toilet yeah
that's the kind of thing that would
never happen in a world of TV or film we
are clearly missing some sort of key
Point here we have our two sides clearly
established but who or what exactly are
we supposed to be rooting for here well
that my friends is where the most recent
episodes come in at the end of episode
47 we see a G-Man toilet destroy the POV
cameraman just like we've seen him do in
many other episodes before but then
through the lens of our fallen camera we
see someone coming into frame and it's
not just anyone it's a person we haven't
seen a human in the series for literally
dozens of episodes and yet out of the
blue a person appears and it's not just
any person either this character looks
an awful lot like de fuke's Channel
Avatar doesn't it like I mentioned
earlier humans didn't really play much
of a role in this franchise prior to
this very moment in the beginning humans
were just cannon fodder for the toilet
overlords but now we have one of these
humans in fact the human who's making
the series inserting himself back into
the narrative and not just here he's
also hidden indoors during the opening
seconds of episode 45 but why One does
not simply self-insert their Avatar Into
A 2 billion view a month Series so
lightly when the story is so deep in its
own narrative unless you have a greater
role to play in The Story You're about
to tell dafook clearly has a love and
passion for this style of video before
skippity exploded he had created dozens
of videos in his sfm YouTube poop format
in fact his two most popular long-form
videos on his channel are still to this
day sfm animations that he made years
ago that being said I also don't think
he totally dislikes the world of TV
movies and music either why would he
make him the protagonists of his epic
internet series if he did I think the
Fook like many other creators aspires to
do this work on a professional level and
you can tell that desire for a
professional higher caliber of work and
the way that he's handled the skimpity
toilet series each episode has seen an
escalation of animation the character
were getting better the idea is bigger
and grander he has literally turned what
started as a YouTube poop into an epic
action movie that hangs with some of the
best content that I've seen this year so
what gives what is the story that he's
trying to tell us through skibby toilets
well to me it's clear from the story
that's laid out in front of us that
defuke sees himself quite literally in
the middle of these two loves of his
that are currently at odds notice what
his character is doing throughout the
series so far he's picking up the broken
remains of the camera heads the broken
remains of traditional media creators
like dafook got into making this kind of
content on the internet not just because
it was fun and easy but deep down they
wanted to emulate the TV film and music
that they enjoyed consuming the Fook
wants to take the elements that make the
new and old media so great and fuse them
together he is the merge point he is the
next step in the evolution of the medium
he's the missing link here I mean look
no further than skimpity toilet itself
the series starts off as a simple gag
that latched onto a viral internet meme
in episode 1 but by episode 50 suddenly
we have cinematic camera changes complex
sound design dazzling visuals and
special effects that feel like they
belong more in the MCU than a YouTube
poop skibity toilet isn't an epic
takedown of toxic internet content or
the corrupt industrial bigwigs at the
studios instead it's evidence that these
two things can co-mingle these two
Titans of entertainment can co-exist
together and be stronger as a result
that The Best of Both Worlds can be
brought together for the greater good of
entertainment so where does this
franchise end up going from here well we
have ourselves our new protagonist in De
fuke who eventually take Center Stage
taking it upon himself to save the world
that he loves the worlds of internet
meme dumb and mainstream media he's
gonna turn out to be the Neo of this
universe he is the chosen one he'll be
the one who'll be able to marry both
sides of this war together and show that
if the two sides put aside their
differences they can create something
truly magical or who knows maybe I'll
get a movie deal out of it and then
truly you've had the merging of the
worlds but hey speaking of blending
ideas from multiple Industries into one
magical product I want to thank our
sponsor for today's video Opera with its
built-in free VPN and ad blocker
integrated browser AI Arya and the
ability to have your music and messenger
apps available at your fingertips feels
like Opera's new browser Opera 1 is the
browser that unites everything that we
love about the internet into one
seamless experience here at theorist
when we're researching videos even tabs
on all of our tabs can feel like a job
unto itself after opening 50 skippity
videos and dozens of fan Wiki Pages
becomes a bit overwhelming to even find
where the script I was working on went
that's why I love Opera one's new tab
Islands feature which allows me to
easily split my tabs into groups that
make sense for my workflow and as I open
similar tabs new tab Islands get created
automatically helping me stay organized
much more easily tab Islands give me the
power and flexibility to focus on what's
on the screen rather than the mountain
of tabs above it upper one also comes
with a new modular design which allows
me to customize all the bells and
whistles to make my browsing experience
truly feel like my experience and not
one that was just arbitrarily chosen for
me but the feature that I love most with
this new Opera one is its native browser
AI Arya Arya was made in collaboration
with openai you know the company that
makes chat GPT but with some new
features to help make it stand apart
Arya is web connected meaning that it
can provide up-to-date information so we
can stay current Arya also makes it
easier to brainstorm ideas rephrase
confusing sentences do quick math all
without having to open up new tabs and
the best part is if I come across some
text in a foreign language or some topic
or phrase that I'm not familiar with I
can just use the Highlight tool tip to
have Arya give me the answers that I
need instantly there really isn't much
you can't do with Opera's new Opera one
so go use the link down in the
description and in the pinned comment to
give Opera one a try give yourself the
better browser experience that you
deserve and as always my friends
remember it's just a theory a film
Theory and yes yes